[Music]  [Music]  we have a friend that just came in from  florida  so we're gonna take your sightseeing i  believe my wife has received some stuff  yes and i do receive some offers here  and they're free play  and in room stays and so forth  california it's  been pretty difficult there's not much  to do there  so we actually like to come to nevada  because it is a little more open  i'm like a kid in disneyland right now  we actually started at  samano casino last night she won six  hand face  six jackpots are you looking to win  tomorrow  absolutely had to take advantage of that  um you know with the  vacation with everything starting to  open again you know it's nice  it's a long weekend too i have my kids  at home so they were able to be off at  school and stuff like that so it worked  out  and we had been at home for so long so  yeah we needed it's my first vacation in  15 years  you